les regards se braquent de nouveau sur
l'iran alors que le pays dénombre le
plus de morts après la chine les
autorités iraniennes doivent faire face
à de lourdes accusations ce dimanche un
élu de la ville de qom foyer initial du
virus accusé le gouvernement de masquer
la vérité et de mentir à la population
selon le représentant la province
dénombrerait plus d'une cinquantaine de
morts
l'anxiété monte au coeur du pays j'ai
vraiment peur il n'y a pas de masque
dans les pharmacies gouvernement devrait
distribuer des masques gratuitement aux
gens s'ils veulent le contenir
nous avons très peur le monde entier
touchées et cela se propage la
télévision d'état nous donne des
statistiques mais quand nous allons à
l'hôpital nous voyons que c'est
différent
le nombre de décès est bien plus élevé
une population de plus en plus méfiante
envers son gouvernement
depuis le scandale du crash du boeing
craignent un abattu par des tirs iranien
une situation sanitaire qui a conduit
les pays voisins de l'iran à fermer
leurs frontières face aux inquiétudes
les autorités iraniennes ont tenu à
rassurer la population et la communauté
internationale sur leur transparence
nous annoncerons le nombre de décès dans
tout le pays
on nous engageons à faire preuve de
transparence en ce qui concerne la
communication des chiffres alors que la
chine se retrouve isolé du monde
l'épidémie qui vient d'apparaître aux
portes de l'europe laisse planer le
spectre d'une pandémie mondiale